[Music]
the Met Gala is fashions biggest night
and let's face it it's also kind of
insane no that is not the open titles to
the next American Horror Story its
Celine Dion at her first met clearly
there is a fine line between fashion and
foolishness and this year's event had it
all and here's the proof
[Music]
j-rod did not disappoint with their red
carpet debut inside JLo got her groove
on dancing while Iran sat back like he
was in a dugout the party continued for
Celine inside getting down with Halle
Berry and also literally on the ground
on the steps to the met meanwhile Kylie
Jenner was apparently not down with
Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds color
Kylie unimpressed and how's this for
trippy
armie hammer sandwiched between the
real-life Winklevoss twins who he played
in the social network back on the red
carpet there were some epic photo bombs
like a starstruck Sarah Paulson spawning
Madonna herself and Lena Dunham lurking
behind Joe Jonas or as Lena calls it her
rightful place now if you thought some
of these gals look outrageous wait until
you see what the stars wore at the after
parties we've got all the pics over at
et online.com
[Music]
you